thank you
[Music]
I want some Sichuan chicken JK the new
Tabasco
leave it in leave it in leave that in
search one chicken that might be on
topic because there is a Chinese
surveillance balloon that is flying over
the northeastern Northwestern United
States I've seen that [__] that's crazy
it looks like the balloon was
camouflaged to look like the moon almost
so that it doesn't draw attention
because it's like a white circular disc
so I think they made it where it's like
if we just had a glass moon or a star or
whatever but then there was a video I
saw where someone's like wait that's the
Moon
is that a moon and then they look like
there's two million it was in Canada
first huh and then Canada's like what
should we do they think it was launched
from there I'm gonna blow it up but
they're like no but then like people
might get hurt when the [__] debris
go down there just let's just let it fly
for a couple days one of my favorite
tweets was this one it says uh people be
like nobody needs a AR-15 LOL Bro
there's Chinese air assets over U.S soil
see this [__] that's like that's true
holy [__] that's crazy dude
it's like it's like 80 000 feet my
question is why do they need to do that
if they already got tick tock
well that's a really good question by
the way because they're literally in
your phone [__] seeing everything
you're doing they [__] get a hot air
balloon some archaic-ass spy machine
should they be Antico no no they got
nice assets they still haven't got it
down at this moment it's still up it's
still up it's yeah China has actually
owned it now because people were saying
this is a conspiracy theory and like
pretty quick early on like we don't know
what it is and then China's like yo
that's our balloons are if I had to
guess I would say they now have uh views
of where our geographical assets are
like our missionary base is here nuclear
power plants here missiles here that
that probably a reason why are they
getting from this they don't get from
satellite imagery like what's yeah they
got Google Earth we all got Google Earth
some think it is a perhaps an experiment
where about maybe enp like they if they
were to detonate EMP pulse us out
continental United States black us out
would be pretty [__] yeah pretty
that's really scary but it's been in
Canada though what's that that's been
Canada no it's over the United States
right now for like they said well the
Pentagon was saying that it will allow
it for a couple days and then they'll
take it down or something but that's
wild right like why it's crazy even a
couple days yeah well if your buds the
US aircraft in the in the international
waters they're they're gonna fire on you
or at least their reasoning was where it
was at it can potentially hurt people on
the ground so that was the reasoning of
since when did they give a [__] about
that they don't have a protocol to
safely take these down that's like
saying there's a missile going over we
can't shoot it down because it's gonna
it's like well you wanna save the whole
country that's like when they're
launching scud missiles in Afghanistan
and then they're like oh no we don't
give a [__] about the people on the
ground
that's a good point give me a break
they're Canadians so that's probably why
they don't want to hurt them but they're
over us now yeah they're over us now
we're hardcore as [__] well maybe they
don't want to hurt the people in the
midwest I don't know the war over less
my friend
the official report is they didn't want
the debris to harm potential people when
the area where it's over send an amber
alert be like go like this for 30
minutes yeah you'll be okay
one of my favorite things you'll like
this bird and you'll like this joke
um there's a guy you guys won't like it
because you don't know [__] about guns
because you're a [__] for brains
well there's a guy
there's a bunch of like there's a bunch
of like right there's a bunch of right
winger dudes who are like who are like
well how come some Hunter hadn't shot it
down yet what a bunch of [__] up
there
dude that's so far yeah would you say it
was 80 000 dude you know what's funny
and AR could reach that my dumb ass
would have been like why don't we just
send the plane up there to bump it it's
a balloon for God's sakes to bump it
back into Canada okay dude send a plane
up there to bump it back into Canada
yeah dude Batman 1989 [__] scissors
that [__] yeah that's right yeah send
the [__] air play skydiver and
pop the balloon if Red Bull can send a
space skydiver just for a video get up
Red Bull oh that's the ultimate social
media hot take isn't it yeah Red Bull
could have done it why can't the United
States do [__] Red Bull may have
accidentally hit that on the way down I
know is that Sean Connor reaction again
I like it that's not much hunger you
don't know who's stronger you don't know
how much you don't just do it again Sean
Connery oh Anthony Lee I see you Anthony
Lee you [__]
wait say the thing he says about a
slapping a woman thing oh yeah what do
you say he said um sometimes I need a
good slap yeah sometimes a woman needs a
good slap [__] love I love the tube
behind it yeah I love that knowing it'll
be in print and just committing and he
just says it just normally he's like
yeah they just do
why are you looking like so China is
owning it like yeah we're spying on you
[__] they've owned it and the
United States government has owned that
they know it's China as well and then
China came out and said they own so like
if they like shoot it down or something
is that scene as like an act of War I
don't know over our airspace but China's
basically saying hey don't worry about
it because it's civilian oh they're
saying it's like a weather data thing
it's mostly just used for like we're
checking some weather [__] but don't you
love them mostly and especially yeah in
China
everything's military-on what the [__]
are you talking about there is no
civilians but mostly for like a data
collection you know like exactly like we
just want to see how many you guys use a
tick tock did it come from Vancouver
what's scary is my earthquake kit and my
Ziploc bag it's just like animal
crackers a Capri Sun a couple of those
things I never thought we would be
full-wide County City Blackout what
about after the damage you didn't get a
bunch of [__] after the demo I did I
have but not enough for a [__]
blackout like that I know isn't that
scary that's crazy add more [__] it's
over friends like we're talking like
total I think Bedlam in the united we
see like the LA people looting now when
the lights are on and there's cops
imagine when cop comms don't work they
can't [__] you can't even call 9-1-1
and the lights are off what kind of
shit's gonna have just goes yeah yeah
California has a lot of Teslas holy [__]
or they just go you really think there's
such an EMP that can can't cover like
that much area I don't know what China's
doing I don't think they got some good
[__] I don't know what grid they would
have to hit but maybe that's kind of
what they're doing I wonder if you have
ever seen other than the Matrix was the
one in Ocean's 11. shout out Don Cheadle
do you guys know if shout out George
Clooney
he's worked the same way that they are
assumed to work like from video games
and movies
different or are they totally fictional
oh yeah I'm watching GoldenEye the James
Bonds movie yeah and that was pretty
sick because it [__] up an entire
because it's super sick every time they
use it but then whenever they do use it
in movies it's not permanent yeah or
it's always like temporary and then it
goes back online also every single time
they use it there's always like that
backup generator that pops on or
something like that you have one I don't
got a generator in my house I should
probably get one you don't have a
generator no dude I just hope that one
when trying it seems like a generator
guy but yeah I know generator no I need
one you have like a buddy that knows
somebody that knows somebody who has
generators team standard you don't even
know you probably built a custom
generator or something like how don't
you have a generator honestly I'm gonna
get one now you're kind of opposing add
to cart right now I'm buying a [__]
generator dude
you're no property the prepper Community
disavows you yeah
feel for that right yeah so you need to
get a couple gallons of gas I don't
think he knew that he's probably about
to pop and lock all over
that I didn't know there was fuel for a
generator yeah the outdoor is longer
than you
think the lights go out and he's like
okay my skills are I'm gonna do the
roly-poly
if Steve's outside for a second type of
ventilating getting sunburns okay I
don't get that so I burned I mean I give
a little bird
you got to get new fuel like every two
three months too that [__] gets old
oh you need some energy what skills do
you have if after this video we're gonna
go talk in the corner I'm like you know
right now what do you got for sunglasses
again he is an eagle scout oh yeah he's
probably had the most survival skills
out of all that's cool all kinds of hell
and not time
if it all goes black you can tie like
you're trying to [__] seven thousand
[__] that's sick dude hey clap back dude
tell me your skills dog his Eagle Scout
stuff
that's a very American tradition he
sprays his ankle I could take a book
wrap it around take a handkerchief and
tie that [__] and then you can walk a
little longer I could be like be careful
that's poison sumac I'll own it I'll own
it I got mode
yeah what's your rebuttal Steve
how would you take care of him he was
Zero he was hurt yeah
and yeah taken care of how are you going
to just laugh and endorse that that's
[__] racist right there these white
people think different dude is that
right you guys are going against the Boy
Scout Association no I'm with him I like
that he knows how to take him a Sprint
I'm calling Anthony dude but then now I
like the beer on his head
visual dude yeah it's a funny visual
are We Done Yet yeah I think we tried to
we got it
laughs
foreign